Adam Brody and Leighton Meester a
millennial Love Story everyone can get
behind it's good for a laugh and now
et's looking back at how the Stars
literally aligned to bring together
Blair Waldorf haven't you heard and Seth
Cohen summer Anna
said yeah Adam became quite the
heartthrob thanks to the OC I kissed you
so true I always knew you were a late
bloomer sweetie when the series signed
off in 2007 Creator Josh Schwartz left
the beach and turned to the Big Apple
with Gossip Girl I was very attracted to
her from John she's a Heavenly creature
which is right around the time Adam and
Leighton first crossed paths literally
the first time we met that whole cast
was eating at campers and I was leaving
and he introduced all of us and then bum
dinner like two or three times over the
next couple years but I had no idea
whether she was a good person or not and
in fact kind of assumed she probably
wasn't for like you know the first
handful years that I didn't know her
just because I don't know Gossip Girl
well fast forward to 2012 Adam and
Leighton co-starred in the oranges
sharing the screen again soon after and
life partners
hi oh God yeah how are you meanwhile the
two are becoming more than colleagues
and made it red carpet official in 2013.
and come to find out like she's
literally Joan of Arc she's like the
strongest best person I know she's my
moral compass and North Star and I just
can't say enough good things about her
character yep the romance took a while
to cook but they made up for lost time
and a year after they first sparked
dating rumors the couple tied the knot
I'm quite happy with my life and I don't
mess with it and ever since Layton and
Adam have opted to keep their private
lives well private especially after
their family got a little bigger the
couple welcomed their first child in
2015. daughter Arlo Dave I think that
it's really important to show your
children that there are different sides
to everything that's Adam and Leighton
chatting with E.T and the couple's first
joint interview where they also poked
fun at their teen drama days
once a year we have a Seth and Blair day
yeah exactly dress up it doesn't excite
us I think because we're just human
beings and I don't know but I mean it's
exciting to us to laugh it's good for a
laugh that's cool and the Stars even
reunited on screen for Leighton sitcom
single parents I am the captain of the
ship and before you meet the only
important passenger on board I need to
know you understand the rules aye aye
captain no the ship stuff is only for me
and the family is still growing in 2020
the parents celebrated the arrival of
their second child a son whose name they
have yet to share and now I've really
doubled up on this kid thing working is
the ultimate like it guilt for everyone
like I want to be here I'm having fun
um and of course I think it's good all
around but you know this world this our
society everything it doesn't really
give us a lot of space for feeling whole
on either end there's never like an easy
way of doing it marriage you know and
it's all having a family it was a new
frontier for me here in a long
commitment you know and you've got
responsibilities I do understand now
it's still a struggle but that it's
healthy to kind of adjust a few things
like there are compromises that need to
be made if you're going to share a life
with someone
[Music]